schools are ditching Google from all
fronts up until the pandemic Google
Classroom interest was increasing year
after year but since 2020 interest in
Google Classroom has struggled to even
reach levels of 2015. instead many
schools are opting for third-party
Solutions like schoology canvas and a
Blackboard it's not just Google's
virtual classrooms that schools were
ditching either scrolls are also
ditching Gmail a quick Google search
will bring up dozens of Articles from
school newspapers detailing the change
here's a few examples if you look up the
opposite however not only do you find a
fewer results but the results that you
do find are often from 2010 and as for
the oso famous Chromebooks these used to
be the go-to devices for many school
districts but more recently schools have
started to complain about them
apparently Chromebooks have very short
lifespans making them a rather bad
investment this is a very bad sign not
just for Google's educational business
but there are office suite as a whole
here's the thing everyday people
virtually never pay for Google Drive or
Google Docs or Gmail because the free
tier is more than enough for most people
so much of the money that Google and
Microsoft makes from such products comes
from corporations and schools Google was
never really able to break into the
corporate Market with their office suite
but it did seem like they were breaking
into the school Market the collaboration
features and online nature of Google's
office suite made it perfect for team
projects and the presentations combine
this with the pandemic and you would
think that schools would be paying
Google more than ever and that was the
case at the beginning when schools
didn't know where to go they turned to a
familiar brand leading to Chromebook
sales marketing by 87 between 2019 and
the 2020 but now that schools have had
time to become familiar with the Google
shortcomings and research other
Solutions it appears that a popular
choice is the ditch Google and here's
why
foreign
to understand why schools are suddenly
ditching Google we first have to take a
look back at why Google became so
popular among schools in the first place
as it was definitely not because it was
the best option I mean if there was
never really any comparison between
Microsoft Office and the g Suite though
G Suite had a few unique features like
easy collaboration and auto saving onto
the cloud Microsoft Office was the clear
winner and this is why corporations
never really jumped on board with a G
Suite they were looking for the best
tools available not to mention people
were already familiar with the Microsoft
Office Suite so going with Microsoft
Office was a no-brainer for schools
however the choice wasn't as clear sure
Microsoft was better but what real value
were the children especially in
elementary school get from Excel or word
the reality was not much I remember back
when I was in kindergarten in first
grade our class would go to the computer
lab every week just to practice typing
as we move into fourth and fifth grade
we would still write height and revise
her essays on paper but when we were
ready for the final draft we would
switch over to computers but that was
really the extent of all computer use so
safe to say Microsoft Office was quite
overkill for most School applications
but it wasn't just office that was
Overkill it was really the whole
computer experience most students had no
use for a full-on Windows machine or
Outlook email client in fact this just
made students harder to manage instead
of working on the final draft of an
essay students would just jump onto
armor games or Miniclip so giving
children access to a computer was often
more of a distraction than a tool not to
mention windows and office were quite
expensive schools often had to Shell out
100 plus dollars to Microsoft alone with
each computer clearly what schools
needed was a cheaper watered-down
version of the whole computer experience
this seems like the perfect opportunity
for Google to step in with the G suite
and that's what they tried doing in 2006
but it wasn't as successful as you might
think while Google's offerings did mesh
better with the needs of schools it
wasn't something that schools really
paid much attention to after all each
scholar only had one or two computer
labs so paying a premium for 25 or 50
computers wasn't the biggest concern not
to mention it schools had full control
of it when they would incur these costs
they could just stick around with
Windows XP in the world 2003 as long as
they wanted so in the late 2000s schools
weren't exactly jumping up and down to
switch to Google but all of this would
change with the 2010s
foreign
popularity within the educational space
can really be summed up by one Trend
schools aiming for a student to device
ratio of one to one suddenly buying
Windows licenses wasn't just a matter of
purchasing 25 or 50. elementary schools
themselves had to buy several hundred
middle schools and high schools had to
buy thousands and colleges had to buy
tens of thousands some richer schools
continued to Shell out money for
Microsoft licenses but this didn't last
for longer as a Microsoft would shoot
themselves in the foot in 2010 Microsoft
would introduce a subscription model for
office called Office 365 and that this
would eventually become the only option
really the only reason for this move was
that a subscription model was more
lucrative for Microsoft than a licensing
model most corporations would just
putting up the cash and jump onto the
subscription because for professional
use the G Suite wasn't really a viable
option for schools however Google's
offerings to order this email a lot more
attractive Google's offerings were not
only cheap starting at just three
dollars per student per year but you
could even get it for free if your
school met certain qualifications around
the same time Google would also come out
with the Chromebook which was also
perfect for schools schools didn't have
to worry about kids doing anything too
crazy with Chromebooks because they
couldn't do much to begin with it turned
out that Chromebooks and the g Suite
were the exact watered down versions of
computers that schools were looking for
and before you knew it schools were
switching to Google left and right this
isn't to say that they ditched Microsoft
completely schools might have still had
a few dozen windows and office based
computers in computer labs but as for
the hundreds and the thousands of
computers that were being issued to
students these were of course
Chromebooks so when Google launched
classroom in 2014 it's no wonder why it
became the go-to option for most schools
but this Heyday for Google education
only lasted for a few years by the late
2010s teachers and students started
noticing quite a few shortcomings you
see Google classroom was nothing more
than a UI to share and manage Google
drive documents and presentations when a
student turns in a document literally
the only thing that's happening is that
the sharing permissions are being
changed the document to get shared with
the teacher and the student loses
editing permissions that that's pretty
much it this in itself was a pretty
crappy solution because students could
no longer edit the document once it was
turned in which didn't really make sense
in a lot of situations also there were
no robust systems for soft grading
assessment announcements grade books
online discussions or meetings just to
name a few these are all basic features
that are available in every other
e-learning solution but despite the
shortcomings most schools put up with
Google throughout the late 2010s because
it was cheap and was mostly sufficient
for their needs but all of this would
change with the pandemic
foreign
there was a massive influx of school
switching to Chromebooks and the Google
Classroom because that's what was
popular but as the pandemic raged on
schools simply started investing in
better Solutions and the reasoning isn't
rocket science virtual classrooms were
no longer an extension to in-person
classrooms for a period of time they
were a flown replacement to in-person
classrooms and even with the shift back
to in-person classes the utilization of
these e-learning platforms is larger
than ever in fact in many schools it
seems that the in-person aspect is now
the extension every homework every quiz
and every test and every project is
completely online the instructions are
posted online the students work together
online and the project is turned in
online basically everything other than
the teacher's lecture itself can be
found on canvas or schoology or whatever
platform the school is using at
universities even the lecturers are
automatically recorded and uploaded onto
these Platforms in terms of cost can
visit does have a free tier but that's
mostly for small scale implementations
for example if you are running a yoga
class or a math tutoring service you
might use a free tier for district-wide
and university-wide implementations
though canvas is not free it's actually
quite expensive canvas doesn't have any
sort of set pricing and each school is
handled on a case-by-case basis but here
are some numbers that are floating
around online it seems that on average
schools have to pin an upfront fee of
several thousand dollars to set up the
initial system plus about 25 per user
per month this could be higher or lower
depending on what level of integration
and The Branding a Givens goes looking
for but that's a ballpark number as you
can see that several times more than
Google's three dollars per month and
free tiers but systems like canvas are
also several times more effective than
Google's tiers and given how heavily
these systems are now utilized at
schools it simply doesn't make sense to
go with their watered down version from
Google the same logic applies to
Chromebooks as well students no longer
go to the computer your lab once a week
to practice typing they use computers
the entire day at school and after
school as well also they're doing an
increasingly complicated tasks nowadays
students are 3D modeling in engineering
classes and coding algorithms and
computer science classes even in middle
school also every job in the world uses
Windows or Mac so it really makes no
sense to train students to use
Chromebooks some districts are even
going as far as purchasing MacBooks and
iPads for students but even those that
aren't going that far are very much
seeing a research instant windows and
office and more professional Tools in
general even though they're more
expensive
foreign
Advantage within the educational space
has also become their greatest weakness
when Tech adoption was still relatively
early stage with schools Google was able
to make a big splash by offering tech
for extremely cheap whether that be
Chromebooks the G Suite or Google
Classroom while these options did have
their shortcomings when the virtual
classroom was simply an addition to
in-person learning they held up all
right but when virtual learning is front
and center the whole Google ecosystem
starts to fall apart we should also
mention that school districts are now
being run by a newer generation that
better understands Tech they realize
that investing in good tech for students
is way more valuable than buying pencils
and papers and desks or even building
new buildings the ROI is simply
incomparable and that that's why schools
are giving up on Google they're simply
leaning towards more professional
solutions that make more sense and are
increasingly Tech driven World education
may not be the only realm in which
Google is losing ground they may also be
losing ground in YouTube but their new
Adblock policies if you want to know why
check out this video but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one